for more on the reaction to this in
washington let's bring in ed o'keefe
who's at the white house ed good morning
to you
tarika good morning there's been no
response from the president or the white
house just yet we may hear from him or
from aids later this morning but there's
been a strongly worded statement
overnight from house speaker nancy
pelosi and senate majority leader chuck
schumer saying together in part that
several of these conservative justices
have lied to the u.s senate ripped up
the constitution and defiled both
precedent and the supreme court's
reputation they call out republicans by
saying that every republican senator who
supported minority leader mcconnell and
voted for former president trump
justices pretending that this day would
never come will now have to explain
themselves to the american people other
republicans meanwhile praising the news
missouri senator josh hawley says the
draft opinion is tightly argued morally
powerful in congress democrats have
tried and failed to pass a bill that
would make abortion rights federal law
the women's health protection act easily
passed the democratic-controlled house
last fall but failed earlier this year
in the evenly divided senate that's
despite cbs news's most recent polling
this is important it shows a majority of
americans support keeping abortion
rights as they are
they also want it to remain legal in
their state if roe is overturned now
remember an end to federal abortion
rights will kick this issue back to the
states which is going to put a huge
emphasis now on big governor's races in
several states across the country that
are also likely to be presidential
battlegrounds in 2024. arizona georgia
wisconsin pennsylvania michigan
democratic candidates in those states
overnight saying abortion rights now
central to their election campaigns and
democrats have been warning since the
high court heard this mississippi
abortion rights case that the midterm
results would likely be scrambled if the
court ultimately decides to toss out
federal abortion rights nate
ed thank you